listen you look very nice tonight come
on man I'm wearing uh oh but you look I
say offer a reason for the Goldbergs
premiere yeah this week you posted a
picture where you're not dressed as
nicely and I want to ask you about it
there are yeah I'm getting wired yeah to
spend by the way they'll wire me and
they hide on the side and that's how I
spend the entire day right like doing
scenes
I don't like tidy whities I'm not a fan
I've never had someone yell that in my
face before
tighty-whities what you don't like this
you know what at the point to be heard
okay but later know so your character
your character wears tell you ways
because I don't like them
no but that's like the eighties man
there were no boxer briefs a big fan of
the boxer brief oh nice you like the
bathroom I do not because I find that
the legs ride up and then you get a
bunch of a bunch of you know crotch ball
like a bunch of fabric all water you
actually said the term rock boy but
isn't that assumed that you'll have an
area that's known as your crotch what
I'm saying is down there real estate
comes at a premium I can't have a bunch
of fabric wadded up my fabric seems to
stay in place I don't know what's going
on down there well whether your your
balls are pulling up Richard it's like
it'll be an hour special on TBS in
November
what's going on down there Andy Richter
can I just say something yeah I would
tune in alright
I'd even host it that was great for me
cuz I just watched that like a play
alright looks like I was at the theater
I just watched by the way aren't there
some nights you go to the theater and
you wish that was the play two guys
talking about their underwear because
now at once
oh I've had many times of theater where
I wish it was that conversation yeah I
don't know underwear
I just wanna ask you something yes just
talked at length about tighty whities
versus boxer briefs and all that
are you comfortable say with nudity with
your naked body are you comfortable with
that and I bring it up for a reason not
everybody is comfortable with that thing
like I don't I don't like to walk around
naked in my house I am so Pro naked it's
unbelievable I look better naked than
you could possibly imagine
no what does that even mean that means
like you wouldn't look at me and go oh
look he's naked I'd like to see that no
III look good naked in the mirror yeah I
don't get disgusted I go Hey look at you
yeah
however look at you look there's my
Goldberg's character Murray when I get
home
pants are off I'm in my underwear boxer
briefs yeah and sometimes my sons their
friends come over and I don't throw in
pants I'm a gay man how you doing
so you wander around in front of your
really your friends in your underwear
yes
however this is something I've thought
about I don't understand why people who
want to get divorced
don't use nudity with an erection what I
mean by that is let's say your wife has
some friends over so your time like in
this case you want to get divorced yeah
went out of a marriage and you walk out
there with a boner with their friends
you're gonna get divorce it'll work out
perfect why are you leaving him well my
friends would come over he'd walk out
with a boner perfectly good excuse to
get divorced yes so it's like just
firing a gun into the air by the way if
I have a gun maybe I'd use that yeah
trying to get divorced but all I'm
saying it's like oh let me go so here's
another one why don't women when they
don't want to do something just say my
vagina hurts what man would argue with a
woman who says my vagina
tonight can I get you some like do you
want to go to the movies tonight now my
vagina hurts what man wouldn't go let me
get you some ice
let me help what can I do no one's gonna
argue with the hurting vagina I never
thought I'd say this but I'm the
yearning for the good old days of the
old ball sack conversation just I'm
chess that's now that's now like 1920s
baseball tonight you had Ted Williams
you had Babe Ruth
[Laughter]
you